those eligible for vaccine include some
nevada seniors but
many are having issues with the sign up
process or go mana now joins us
to share their frustrations and really
just walk us right through the process
it's just extremely frustrating 76 year
old las vegas arlene ferris has been
trying to book an appointment to get the
covet 19 vaccine but like many
she's running into some roadblocks you
click on it and then it says no it's not
available
scary you know i've had a heart attack
i've had a stroke
and i would think i would would be a
priority
the southern nevada health district's
website has options for nevada in 70 and
older but thursday night the calendar
skipped ahead showing no availability
the health district is asking for
everyone's patience saying new dates can
be added at any time
that's what happened when ginger allen
went online to help her 79 year old
mother claire
a lot of the locations don't have
availability so i had to
you know scroll through the different
locations to find a one that had
openings
they finally scheduled an appointment
for next week i'm really
looking forward to to doing it just just
just
for myself for everybody danielle caprio
still can't get a spot for her 79 year
old mother roseanne but says it's
understandable
it's a new website it's you know this
whole thing is new for everybody so
obviously
you know probably expect some technical
issues ferris wants to get the vaccine
without an appointment and hopes the
health district makes some changes
i don't mind waiting two or three hours
in the car if that's what it's going to
take
orco mana 8 news now again the health
district is asking
for your patience in this matter they
say to check their calendars
often because apparently expanded
capacity and cancelled appointments
could ultimately lead to additional
openings so keep an eye on that
frequently
we have a link to it on our website at
8newsnow.com